about just how accurate are the memories
that we know are true, that we believe in?
There is decades of research,
examples and examples of cases like this,
where individuals
really, really believe. None of those teenagers
who identified him
thought that they were picking the wrong person.
None of them thought they couldn't see the person's face.
We all have to be very careful.
All our memories are reconstructed memories.
They are the product of what we originally experienced
and everything that's happened afterwards.
They're dynamic.
They're malleable. They're volatile,
and as a result, we all need to remember to be cautious,
that the accuracy of our memories
is not measured in how vivid they are
nor how certain you are that they're correct.
Thank you. (Applause)